have either of you heard of a mass
formation professor matthias desmet
speaks of this thanks for the continued
sharing of sanity and the person writing
links to um
a piece um
about dr matthias desmond and i'm just
going to read the four conditions that
this person um
thomas m casey
no thomas
sorry thomas casey says about what what
the four conditions are four conditions
need to be present to create mass
formation
one
there needs to be a lot of socially
isolated people or people who experience
a lack of social bond
two
people who experience a lack of
sense-making unable to come to sensible
conclusions
three there was a lot of free-floating
anxiety free-floating because there's
nothing to connect their anxiety to no
focal point unable to identify what's
causing it and so no way to deal with it
and four there's also a lot of
free-floating psychological discontent
people may experience their daily lives
as lacking any purpose or meaning
um so we've certainly got
met all of those uh four things you want
to say something more about mass
formation
yeah i am
persuaded there's something important in
this model i've been tracking it for i
don't know a month month and a half
um
and the idea is that what we are seeing
are people behaving under something akin
to hypnosis hypnosis
a kind of hypnosis that kicks in when
these conditions uh attain
and
i must say uh i don't
feel that you and i are under this
hypnosis and i do feel that we are
encountering a world full of people that
is behaving almost as if they are
sleepwalking on autopilot under some
kind of hypnosis
who are not
in many cases acting according to their
own character and values
and so this is very alarming um
and you know i think we've been we've
been trying to raise the alarm about
this you know for example i think we
were
uh we may have been
the first if not we were very early in
pointing out
that this trope about portraying
uh some segment of society as
disease-ridden
right as subhuman and disease ridden
is extremely ominous because it is the
precursor to behaviors in which you do
away with such people and you are
entitled to do away with those people
for one thing you don't have to worry
too much about them because they weren't
even fully human to begin with and for
another thing they are causing disease
and therefore each one of them
represents like a walking source of
death yeah there's so many reason
they're reasons that they're gross and
dispensable right and so we now see this
portrayal again and again i saw it as
recently as today
in uh
an article
i believe it was the washington
post talking about the number of
deaths this year as compared to last
year which is something i want to return
to
um maybe next live stream i think wall
street journal maybe oh maybe it was the
wall street journal
um but in any case it very clearly
paints a picture that is not borne out
by the evidence at all
in which yes it's those pesky
unvaccinated who are causing the rest of
us to be in danger of this deadly
disease and it's like that story doesn't
even add up right of course as many
people have recognized there's something
weird about a vaccine that requires
other people to get it in order for it
to work to protect you
um right that's not a high quality
vaccine at the very least um it's a
lackluster might not be deserving of the
name
right maybe
we
might not have been deserving of an
experiment in which we attempt to
vaccinate the entire world but
okay
so anyway yes mass formation
is well worth tracking i don't know that
it's a hundred percent accurate as a
model but i will say
if you walk around thinking am i dealing
with um
hypnotized people and is that why
they're behaving this way it seems to be
more enlightening than it is confusing
so anyway keep tracking it
[Music]